[Music]
is that coming damn hey girl hey Dad
hello there what was our rule right and
what were you doing just now okay hey
hey hey I'm naked
yeah yes yes we watched a video no we
were gonna say 'no but i can't lie to
jake and besides we just skimmed it
because we didn't have time oh my god
I think this might be no it definitely
is the most embarrassing moment you
should not feel embarrassed if anything
you should feel proud yeah your body's
insane oh look at this one this little
one is flexible yeah it's really good
Oh fantastic so you do like the lizard
now is when we transfer the energy you
see no you just lay everything on top of
her yeah that feels pretty good huh boom
what boom am i straight enough here do
you think am i curving a little let me
show you and feel the transfer of the
air it won't feel solid it is tantric
energy it is feel good okay cuz it hurts
me would you do that for me no no God
put our mouths on her head yep I'm all
set dad yeah no I I think he's trying to
watch some illegal channels here illegal
illegal channels this is just a bad
reception honey what's it you know what
you're just give me this please
okay okay so unique
come here I need this I need them I need
you
I don't need one heartbeat
I need two
[Music]
you or something I want to roll you into
a little ball shove you up my vagina you
could just live there it's warm its cozy
walk around with you man
just know I have I feel a little
ticklish grass this is your hair huh
I live in China please just do it for me
I'm gonna perform a procedure on you
called milking the prostate it's an
anally induced ejaculation you're gonna
feel strong pressure on the prostate
gland from inside your rectum oh stop
okay keep doing it yeah all done
that was awesome
[Music]